hey guys so we were
watching a movie just now and then
you got a notification like we were
literally just watching a movie and
you got a notification about chadwick
boseman apparently passing away
yeah i just heard this seconds ago
this as of shooting this video this news
is only like
less than 10 minutes old wow like and we
were just happen to be like here
watching something yeah like what the
hell
and at first i thought it was fake and
so i went to look and sure i know it
sounded fake at first but
yeah um okay so we got
we got some information here yeah we got
his twitter feed pulled up here where i
guess
his family's released a statement it is
with immeasurable grief that we
confirmed the passing of chadwick
bozeman
jesus christ chaswick was diagnosed with
stage 3 colon cancer in 2016.
what wow i heard
we heard rumors about this but i thought
people like chalked up
like him like looking all skinny for
that uh the
spike lee moves yeah and battled it with
these last four years as it progressed
to stage four wow a true fighter
persevered though it threw it all wow
this is so
shocked and brought you many of the
films you have come to love from
marshall to defy bloods august wilson's
morainey's black bottom and several more
all were filmed during in between
countless surgeries and chemotherapy
it was the honor of his career to bring
king to child to life in black panther
he died in his home
jesus [ __ ] christ with his wife and
family by his side
the family thanks you for your love and
prayers and ask that you continue to
respect their privacy during this
difficult time
i can't believe this yeah it's i'm i'm
in a little bit of shock because it's
yeah it's out of nowhere and it's not
like it's up
to you know people in the public eye to
keep us abreast of their medical
concerns but yeah
this is it's a it's a blind side and you
have to think of
you know his rise over the past several
years especially and like reaching that
pinnacle with black panther like i i
have so many questions now and i think
it's like the people at marvel must have
known and it's
it's wonderful of them to have just yeah
like moved ahead anyway i guess you know
i mean i don't know exactly what all the
timeline is but at the same
time yeah
this week has been such
a heavy week with everything going on
man and
i i cannot believe this i i
only just watched 42. yeah i
only like very very very recent
and he has constantly been one of those
actors who we've
praised is like this guy's more than
black panther but what
well what he did with bringing black
panther to life being such an iconic
role
and 43 that's so young that's pretty
[ __ ] young that's incredibly young
especially
for for i mean you know cancer can
strike anybody but you know especially
to hear somebody losing their life this
way it's yeah
it's too young
i've seen so many interviews with the
guy and i've never
you would never guess anything never
would have guessed anything and
um the man's brought me to tears off of
like certain interviews that he's had
yeah like yeah like his interviews alone
he's he's
he's demonstrated himself to be a very
compassionate
and passionate passionate human being as
well
a guy who's a versatile talent i feel so
bad for his family
yeah i mean it sounds like everybody got
to kind of hold on
in the most i can't i just can't
believe this yeah
please send love and prayers to his
family
um watch his movies just
celebrate celebrate his life yeah
like he did more than black panther
before what he did with black panther is
such a phenomenal achievement and
yeah this is i thought this was fake
when you first said it i did too
i was like i was gonna be some joke yeah
gosh i
there was a moment of hope in my lungs
when i at first didn't see much in the
results on google and then
you know yeah wow this is so surprising
i'm just trying to find like any other
information that i mean
that must be it that must be
that's it for now i mean i'm sure
tomorrow we'll hear more but
damn it's not exactly but it's it's just
kind of it's like that
it is like that james dean legacy [ __ ]
of just like this guy was just yeah
he was just catapulted me what the hell
he'd had some really huge successes and
yeah it was one of those things where
it's only upward from here like i can't
wait to see the various things that he's
doing and it's just so shocking because
like
i mean like he seemed like such a
he seemed like a healthy athletic guy
right
he seemed like a healthy athletic dude
and
it's it wouldn't
they're saying he's had it for so many
years at this point like four years at
this point
um
what the [ __ ] yeah jesus
may he rest in peace um
love and prayers loving prayers my god
anyway yeah okay
i don't really know how to end this uh
yeah send his family some love and
prayers please complete and yeah
continue to be respectful and such loss
is never easy
grab one of those movies and revisit it
tonight
take care guys